but here we have the president united
states he's so pissed off that they
won't allow him to go to the capitol to
crown be crowned king or whatever he
thought was going to happen
so upset that he was he was willing to
physically put his hands on the person
who was going to protect him what do you
make of that that image yeah look i've
seen donald trump throw temper tantrums
on a handful of occasions in my book
disloyal i actually uh cite one incident
which was against don jr when don jr
said the wrong thing uh while we were at
the wwe raw uh where there was a schtick
going on with him and vince mcmahon for
the purchase and then the sellback of
the wwe to him uh don said the wrong
thing it was a pretty innocuous
statement uh
that
do you ever get nervous going out in
front of big crowds like this in essence
what don was trying to do is to tell his
dad it's a huge crowd because even back
then
size matters for trump and obviously not
according to stormy daniels but size
matters um you know in trump land and
that set him off to the point you know
that he went ballistic don jr got thrown
out of the room i ended up leaving to go
talk to him you know because he was
obviously upset over his father's
reaction but i've seen other events
where trump starts slamming his hand you
know on the desk and so and you would
think you know that he broke his hand
that's how hard that he hid it but you
know who these actions remind me a lot
of is like the actions of like kim
jong-un um you know when
he behaves in a way which is so
narcissistic and dictatorial that i'm
not shocked at anything that came out of
cassidy's mouth today i'm just
disappointed that this information
didn't find its way to the american
people
months and months and months ago
especially during the second impeachment
how dangerous how dangerously close were
we
to donald trump um
bullying these people into doing what he
wanted to do and tearing down our
democracy you have to give them you have
to give them a lot of credit for
standing up it is not easy and i've also
said this uh ad nauseam it is not easy
standing up to donald trump uh the guy
is beyond vindictive the man knows no
shame he has no empathy so he will go to
any length out there in order to get
what it is that he wants including
putting his own life and everybody
else's life in jeopardy by grabbing a
hold of a steering wheel while the beast
which is like a 20 000 pound vehicle i
mean the doors i don't know if you've
ever been in the beast or felt the beast
i've closed the doors um you know to the
beast um you know with myself when i was
allowed to sit inside of it um those
doors weigh like 10 000 pounds i mean
it's crazy and he grabbed the wheel of
the beast while it's in motion simply
because the
baby in chief wasn't getting what he
wanted he didn't get a chance to go
march with people he allowed weapons to
be you know brought close you know to uh
you know to the to the rally that he was
speaking he put everyone's life in
jeopardy but here's the thing that
cassidy stated and it's true
his only thought was that they will not
hurt me these are my people so he
doesn't give a [ __ ] if it was your life
in jeopardy or anybody else maybe a
journalist from cnn or msnbc or abc nbc
cbs it didn't make a difference to him
who was there who can get hurt knowing
that they wouldn't hurt him he wanted to
be there he actually wanted to walk them
through the capital that's how i see you
know knowing him as well as i do that's
what he wanted to do to lead the charge
hoping that that would intimidate mike
pence to call the whole thing off then
he would end up taking over and
remaining as president whether it was
for an extra day or an extra year or
whatever it might be the man is a
narcissistic sociopath who has
autocratic tendencies and
somehow or another he managed to
bamboozle his way you know into the
white house and become the worst version
of himself ever imaginable i never
thought that this would be the way that
i remember you know the legacy of donald
trump ever
nothing went on in the white house
without donald trump knowing about it
firsthand nothing ever went on at the
trump organization without donald trump
knowing about it firsthand from the
acquisition of real estate to the
purchasing of paper clips the man was
involved in every single aspect of both
the company and the white house which he
ran exactly the same way